[Music]
there is a myth
that
the best way the only way to be
successful professionally and
financially is if you have a college
degree like it's a magic ticket to a
better future well i think more and more
people are becoming aware that that's a
myth george so uh
i wrote a blog for the mothership uh
ramseysolutions.com it's entitled 25
high paying jobs that don't
require
a four-year degree and so you and i uh
this is a reveal it's kind of fun for us
we chose during the break some of our
favorite jobs and why
in this category yeah so um
based on our last call i thought i'd
start with one of mine okay hit me um
and we had ryan on the line and she
wants to uh she's in the process of is
is she going to decide to take a
carpentry course to become a carpenter
well it just so happens that
one of the 25 high-paying jobs that
doesn't require a four-year degree is
carpenter
and the median salary now let me explain
this to some folks because i've done
social media posts george get crushed on
tick-tock because people don't pay
attention they don't understand i didn't
remember say it's the income i'm saying
it's the median and let's explain what
median is george tell folks at home
median means middle middle so if you
take the high not average by the way
middle so if you take the high across
the country all 50 states
and you take the low
this is the median the middle
of the range
you'll learn this you didn't learn after
that well but people don't care on
social media they just want to hammer
you so here we go
thank you very much
you know what james is gonna i'm gonna
hear about that one later that's perfect
i don't even know i said that
oh boy okay so what's the median salary
for carpenter folks forty nine thousand
five hundred dollars education needed
high school diploma and some form of
apprenticeship so there you go what do
you got george i have electrician
another trade i just had an electrician
at the house oh yeah and then i got the
bill and i went oh boy
okay hey he's doing well but i'm not
messing with those wires no okay and
median salary for electricians fifty
seven thousand dollars education needed
diploma apprenticeship and there's
positive job growth in that area okay
all right let's go a little more
high-tech george what about a radiologic
or mri technologist oh that's a good one
now this isn't going anywhere this is
healthcare right like you talk about
stability george also pays really well
median salary sixty three thousand seven
hundred ten dollars what education do
you need associate degree only so boy
that's that's budget friendly i like
that that's a two-year community college
let's go let's go let's go
without the tag from med school that's
right leaving the old bill there yeah
nice okay this one's personal this one's
close to home executive assistant was
number 11 on your list i know why median
salary 63 000 and education needed high
school diploma and this is close to home
because my wife is an executive
assistant here at ramsey solutions and
if you know ramsey solutions and you
know that the uh crowd here we have a
huge huge team of assistants yeah and
then on top of that there's executive
assistants that serve our operating
board members our senior leaders and my
wife is one of those rock star executive
assistants that serves someone on our
operating board that reports to dave and
she crushes it and so i think that's a
great great option for folks out there
uh beyond the old school mentality of a
secretary this is so much more this is a
partnership with leaders to help them
accomplish what they want okay they
truly are the gatekeepers that make the
world go round it's basically they're
ceos that's how i like to see it all
right here's let's do a couple more real
quick occupational therapy assistant
this is a median salary of sixty
thousand nine hundred fifty dollars only
need an associate degree and listen to
this if you're in the people business
you love taking care of others you would
call yourself a caretaker great job here
this is all about helping people learn
and practice skills to live and work
most of it takes place after someone has
had some type of accident or elderly
people who need performing help
performing daily tasks around their
homes so another a really people-centric
job good money yeah let me hit you with
one more this is a big one web developer
oh yeah man median salary 77 thousand
dollars yeah and education needed an
associate's degree and even now there's
so many options out there affordable
courses online and companies are so
hungry for web developers i mean we are
hiring them like crazy right now here at
ramsay solutions and you don't need to
go to the fancy name brand school to get
the degree in computer engineering
software engineering and there's some
crazy growth in that area and by the way
that's the median salary you're going to
be in the six figure range pretty quick
if you are good
let me also tell you if you have people
skills as a developer watch out all
right one more we got to give one uh
that is uh a associate's degree required
only
and george's is over six figures high
demand now it's high stress so if you
are a low pulse kind of person you
handle high stress pretty easily air
traffic controller might be
the gig for you airplanes aren't going
anywhere median salary george you ready
for this 130 000
dollars so there you go median yeah if
you'd like to see the entire list dive
into it a little bit more to learn what
it takes to win in those areas uh you
can search that blog up
ramseysolutions.com25 high paying jobs
that don't require a four year degree